testing testing 1 2 3 when your band is
trying to perform feedback is an
annoying obstacle but in the grand
orchestra of nature feedback is not only
beneficial it's what makes everything
work
what exactly is feedback the key element
whether in sound the environment or
social science is a phenomenon called
mutual causal interaction where X
affects Y Y affects X and so on
creating an ongoing process called a
feedback loop and the natural world is
full of these mechanisms formed by the
links between living and nonliving
things that build resilience by
governing the way populations and food
webs respond to events when plants die
the dead material enriches the soil with
humus a stable mass of organic matter
providing moisture and nutrients for
other plants to grow the more plants
grow and die the more humus is produced
allowing even more plants to grow and so
on this is an example of positive
feedback an essential force in the
build-up of ecosystems but it's not
called positive feedback because it's
beneficial rather it is positive because
it amplifies a particular effect or
change from previous conditions these
positive or amplifying loops can also be
harmful
like when removing a forest makes it
vulnerable to erosion which removes
organic matter and nutrients from the
earth leaving less plants to anchor the
soil and leading to more erosion in
contrast negative feedback diminishes or
counteracts changes in an ecosystem to
maintain a more stable balance consider
predators and their prey
when links eat snowshoe hares they
reduce their population but this drop in
the Linksys food source will soon cause
their own population to decline reducing
the predation rate and allowing the hare
population to increase again the ongoing
cycle creates an up-and-down wave-like
pattern maintaining a long-term
equilibrium and allowing a food chain to
persist over time feedback processes
might seem counterintuitive because many
of us are used
more predictable linear scenarios of
cause and effect for instance it seems
simple enough that spraying pesticides
would help plants grow by killing pest
insects but it may trigger a host of
other unexpected reactions for example
if spraying pushes down the insect
population its predators will have less
food as their population dips the
reduced predation would allow the insect
population to rise counteracting the
effects of our pesticides
note that each feed back is the product
of the links in the loop add one
negative link and it will reverse the
feedback force entirely and one weak
link will reduce the effect of the
entire feed back considerably lose a
link and the whole loop is broken but
this is only a simple example since
natural communities consists not of
separate food chains but networks of
interactions feedback loops will often
be indirect occurring through longer
chains a food web containing twenty
populations can generate thousands of
loops of up to twenty links in length
but instead of forming a disordered
cacophony feedback loops in ecological
systems play together creating regular
patterns just like multiple instruments
coming together to create a complex but
harmonious piece of music wide-ranging
negative feedbacks keep the positive
feedbacks in check like drums
maintaining a rhythm you can look at the
way a particular ecosystem functions
within its unique habitat as
representing its trademark sound ocean
environments dominated by predator prey
interactions and strong negative and
positive loops stabilized by self
damping feedback are powerful and loud
with many oscillations desert ecosystems
where the turnover of biomass is slow
and the weak feedbacks
loop through dead matter are more like a
constant drone and the tropical
rainforest with its great diversity of
species high nutrient turnover and
strong feedbacks among both living and
dead matter is like a lush panoply of
sounds despite their stabilizing effects
many of these habitats and their
ecosystems develop and change over time
as do the harmonies they create
deforestation may turn lush tropics into
a barren patch like a successful
ensemble breaking up after losing its
star performers but an abandoned patch
of farmland may also become a forest
over time like a GarageBand growing into
a magnificent Orchestra